your album is out i'm sure you have a
lot to celebrate because of the record
but you're also turning 30. that is a
milestone birthday yeah so knowing what
you know now like what would you say is
the biggest lesson you have learned over
these last 30 years
huh i don't know i can't answer that
question because there's so many
but um you know staying staying true to
who i am growing
um finding my own voice is was really
important to me and now now i understand
that i am in control of my life i make
my own decisions and i'm my own boss
yeah i mean do you feel like uh there's
a part of you that still has things on
your bucket list that you really want to
achieve or do in your life or your
career and if so of course of course you
know my bucket list doesn't include
things like jumping out of the plane
because it doesn't i've already done
that i've done it
um and i'm like as i get older i'm like
more terrified of things so i like won't
do that again but um you know things
like having a family is really important
to me and it's that once again it's it's
the substance of life
i love that looking back and knowing
everything that you've been through do
you ever get a chance to look at the
mirror and just tell yourself how proud
you are of you because yeah you yeah
because i'm proud of you like it's kind
of amazing to see your journey and and
exactly how you became who you are today
so it must be a moment of reflection for
you especially knowing that it's like 30
years right yes
it's i've been through a lot you know
and i'm really proud of myself and
sometimes i look in the mirror and i
just say i'm so proud of you
you're doing great and i love you well
we're here to celebrate you because we
love you too and plus it's a big
birthday so we actually have a little
surprise for you oh my god
okay debbie it's my favorite cake too
right you could tell what it is right
it's susie cakes yes it's the best cake
thank you so much happy birthday
thank you
yes
and thank you for not making me sing to
you because i could not
happy birthday thank you so much
[Music]
congratulations i mean eighth studio
album how about that yeah it's kind of
crazy i never thought i'd put out eight
albums but i'm happy about it an amazing
body of work and this one though because
i had a chance to finally listen to it
it's a headbanger i mean i just imagine
myself like rocking out to in the car in
the kitchen just like an oversized
t-shirt and just like giving them hell
you know oh yeah that's the goal right
while i was listening to it i just kept
thinking it must feel so good for you to
like just like let it all out yeah you
know it's like me going back to my roots
right and it feels so good to just be
completely authentic
and what makes me happy to perform and
sing and i'm just like really really
excited about it you know i usually ask
artists when they're putting out a new
album like what do you want your fans to
know about this next era but i'm curious
like what how do you think they will
interpret this next era of music for you
i don't know that's going to be up to
them you know i can't really
interpret it for them but i hope what
they take from the album is that
i'm back to
myself and
um i hope they have a great time
listening to it
[Music]
well one thing that's consistent with
your records whether it's a bop or a
ballot i feel like you're always
speaking some truth you know sometimes
hard truth uh what kind of stories were
inspiring this record everything that
i've been through especially like over
the past year um
you know i've gone through a lot and i
realized a lot about myself and i
realized what did i what i wanted to say
in my music
yeah i also feel like you know the
beauty of music right is that it is open
to interpretation and and fans can
relate to your story or they can kind of
like you know create their own story for
them when they listen to this
do you pay attention to when they're
just kind of deciphering what the lyrics
mean do you pay attention to their
interpretations of that um you know
sometimes they'll tell me and it's
really really cool to hear their
interpretations from them themselves um
you know whatever the media and the
press take from it is what they
um ultimately are going to do and so i
don't pay a ton of attention to it i
don't really like reading things about
my music i like just putting it out
there so once it's out there it belongs
to everyone else yeah really yeah wow
but it must also feel because you
co-wrote almost every song on this right
every song every song so you co-wrote
every song on this record it must have
felt really cathartic too to get it out
on paper yes absolutely it just felt so
exciting to create songs of my own and
messages that were really important to
me absolutely let's talk about uh
substance because i was telling you it's
stuck in my head
[Music]
again another song that's kind of open
to interpretation but for me i felt like
it's about you know not settling and
also looking for that kind of genuine
connection with exactly exactly that's
what i wanted people to take from the
song yeah so what are you looking for
when you're looking for a genuine
connection
what i'm looking for is you know looking
people straight in the eyes not spending
too much time on my phone and
the distractions that we have in our
everyday life you know it's important
for me to go sit in the grass and enjoy
the sun things like that i feel like
it's easier said than done sometimes in
your business and in this industry like
how do you ground yourself and find that
and carve that out for yourself you know
there's things like meditation there's
things like working with a spiritual
coach and
also just staying true to who you are
and
you know standing on your own two feet
and um staying strong and like i said
true to who you are and the older you
get do you feel like it's easier for you
to say yes to certain things and no to
others you know and put yourself first
yes what's cool about that is i've
really figured out who i am
and i say that a lot every every time i
get older you know but it's like i've
never felt so sure of myself and
grounded that's so liberating like
whatever feeling that is yes you know
speaking of good feelings you're about
to go on tour you're rehearsing for
twitter it's your first tour in what
four years yes i mean how excited are
you to like not only see your fans again
but to perform this record live yes it's
it i'm so excited to reconnect with my
fans in person
see them face to face and see them
enjoying the music their writer dies
aren't they yes my robotics are ride or
die they're like whatever you want to
put out we're going for it we're yes
we're wearing the band tees i'm ripping
it up and i'm going yes yes i see them
and i i am so grateful for all of them
what do you want those fans to know
about this show what can they expect
when they come see this tour um like i
said i'm back to my roots and i am no
longer performing in like little
leotards and stilettos you know trying
to be someone that i thought people
wanted from me
and now i just get to be myself my
genuine authentic self and perform the
songs that i want to perform get to see
more of you just like playing guitar
yeah exactly
i love it um okay so down before show
though do you have like a pre-show
ritual or warm-up and i guess in this
case like how do you kind of get
yourself amped up because this is a rock
show well first of all it's been a while
so i'm gonna have to figure that out
when i'm on the road but vocal warm-ups
are really really important today okay
uh you've always been so open in your
music right i mean is that part of the
job kind of terrifying for you like
obviously you're working through those
emotions in the music but then like you
said then it belongs to everyone else
like what are your like what are your
emotions when right before a release
like this
my emotions right before i release i get
really anxious you do i do get stressed
because the the part of my
process that i really enjoy is creating
yeah so once it's out there i just like
don't really look at things online what
people say and i just wish for the best
yeah so in a lot of ways is it more for
yourself like this piece of work or yes
this is all me this is who i am and i
can't wait for the world to hear it
[Music]